The first proper footballs were made from animal bladders,...
...blown up by mouth and then hand-tied.
These burst easily, prompting the development of more solid leather...
...and cork encased versions in Britain during the 18th and 19th centuries.
In 1872, England's football association...
...set down the first guidelines about ball design,...
...stating that it should be spherical with a circumference of 68 centimeters,...
...cased in leather, weighing between 396 and 453 grams at the start of play.
The weight at kickoff was important as early footballs...
...tended to absorb water, often doubling in weight...
...during the course of the match.
It was common for a player to suffer concussion after heading the ball.
The ball's shape often became distorted towards the end of matches.
During the 1970 tournament,...
...balls were coated with polyurethane to eliminate water absorption...
...but it wasn't until 1986 that the World Cup saw its first fully synthetic football.
The official match ball for the 2018 World Cup...
...is an update of the classic Telstar design...
...used at the 1970 World Cup.
It was the first to be decorated with black panels...
...designed to stand out on black-and-white televisions...
...and change football design forever.